be bold but now how to pay for your
ideas words of wisdom from former
President Obama to a group of New
Democratic lawmakers correspondent Peter
Doocy reports on how the advice was
received on Capitol Hill the Democrat
who won on a promise of hope and change
just told Democratic House freshman he
hopes they change their approach Barack
Obama huddled with House freshmen and
according to the Washington Post quote
he said we as Democrats shouldn't be
afraid of big bold ideas but also need
to think in the nitty-gritty about how
those big bold ideas will work and how
you pay for them 44s advice resonated
with freshman congresswoman Katie Hill
but for Democrats running for president
the pricey progressive pitches keep
coming like a plan to give every teacher
in America a $13,500 raise for three
hundred fifteen billion dollars over ten
years we're gonna pay for it by
adjusting the the estate tax right now
it's only eleven million dollars and up
and we need to lower that another
popular progressive plan actually made
it to the Senate floor today for a
procedural vote
the green New Deal which would cost
trillions a year to implement Mitch
McConnell says he was just giving
presidential candidates in the chamber a
chance to support a campaign trail
staple no senator voted in the
affirmative but the vote was never
expected to pass now suddenly they want
a vote on the green new deal we will not
fall for this stunt
Gillibrand voted present so did every
other Democrat running for president
pretty obviously a vote present today is
a vote in favor of the green New Deal
green New Deal sponsor Democratic
senator Ed Markey didn't think the
resolution was ready we will not allow
the Republicans to make a mockery of our
democratic process but there was nothing
Marky could do to stop Senator Mike Lee
from taking the floor with a huge photo
of Aquaman I draw your attention mr.
president to the 20-foot impressive sea
horse he's writing under the green New
Deal this is probably Hawaii's best bet
when critics pointed out that
eliminating air travel or maybe even
meat could be unfeasible Democrats
running for president jumps to defend
the green New Deal but today none of
them voted to advance it so the green
New Deal resolution earned zero votes in
the Senate just 60 short of the 60 it
needed to advance John Peter Doocy
forests that I cover in that Peter thank
you